on le sait après un certain âge les
réflexes la vigilance la vue et
l'audition baisse autant de facteurs qui
accentuent les risques pour la conduite
c'est pourquoi certains sont aujourd'hui
pour interdire aux conducteurs de plus
de 70 ans de prendre le volant plusieurs
terrible affaire impliquant des
personnes âgées ont fait la une de
l'actualité ces dernières années le
chauffard de 68 ans qui avait pris
l'autoroute a6 en contresens avait
heurté un autre véhicule tuant sur le
coup un père de famille de 38 ans il à
faire terriblement marquantes pourtant
les seniors ne sont pas la tranche de la
population qui provoque le plus
d'accidents
aujourd'hui la sécurité routière n'a
fixé aucune limite d'âge
concernant la conduite il est simplement
conseillé de faire évaluer régulièrement
ses capacités ont de nombreuses victimes
et leurs proches
ces mesures sont loin d'être suffisantes
pour éviter des accidents causés par nos
ainé alors faut-il faire repasser le
permis aux seniors de plus de 70 ans
ce soir maxime fils de hervé mort après
avoir été percuté par un chauffard de 89
ans ou livrera ce soir son témoignage il
fera face à hervé sceaux et président de
l'institut français des seniors pour lui
pas question de refaire passer le permis
ou plus de 70 ans maxime merci merci
beaucoup et merci à hervé sauzay
président de l'institut de conseil des
seniors
maxime vous êtes le fils de hervé sa
mort après avoir été percuté par un
chauffard un chauffard de 89 ans ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter ce qui s'est
passé alors tout bêtement mon père
venait me chercher au collège quand
j'avais 13 ans donc j'ai 20 ans la
quantité dont il ya sept ans ouais c'est
ça et donc à 16h allure normale vu que
j'étais derrière
pas d'excès et une personne âgée de 89
ans nous a coupé la route à un stop et
mon père est mort sur le coup et moi
j'ai eu de graves blessures et tout ce à
quoi j'étais avec lui le massage et ueno
c'est une histoire alors vous avez juste
un petit peu été blessé pour baisser
vous avez encore des séquelles ou pas
non j'ai plus de séquelles mais j'ai
quand même pas mal eu beaucoup de
dommages corporels comme je suis j'ai
passé une semaine dans le coma prêt
d'armand de souffrances on va animer
partir votre papa mais lui c'est
françois hollande c'est sûr qu'avec
l'âge il avait 39 ans il ya là où 40 39
ans lui conduisait et piloter tout
bêtement
voilà et qu'il est même quand on a un
très bon pilote loyer
en moto et il faut avoir confiance à
ceux qui sont autour et la personne de
81 devant elle soient là vous lui avez
parlé cette personne après non non non
j'ai peu l'occasion le problème après la
personne n'a rien vu elle a eu juste le
nez cassé suite à leur buzz quoi
aujourd'hui en france il n'existe aucune
limitation d'âge concernant la conduite
inhumaine des contrôles c'est quelque
chose que vous regrettez je pense soit
que ça devrait être mis en place
cette part repasser le permis
directement mais directement peut-être
en premier temps faire des contrôles à
partir de 60 ans peut-être les personnes
tous les deux en faire des contrôles de
réflexe je sais pas de vue les routiers
je sais que ils ont des contrôles comme
s'améliorer les conducteurs n'ont alors
selon les chiffres de la sécurité
routière les plus de 65 ans sont
pourtant pas les automobilistes qui sont
les plus responsables des accidents
mortels sur la route mais c'est vrai que
la question elle est de plus en plus
posée parce qu'il ya des gens qui ne
repasse jamais le permis qui on et 90 95
en 80 voix 89 ans qui se retrouve au
volant d'une voiture et là c'est
extrêmement grave parce que ça ça a
coûté la vie au papa de maxime et c'est
vrai que moi quand j'ai entendu le
témoignage de maxime
je me suis dit il faut légiférer là
dessus vous pensez que non nicolas
pernikoff alors mis à deux pays
européens qui sont l'exception c'est la
france et l'allemagne qui ont des permis
illimitée dans la plupart des pays
européens il faut savoir que dès que
vous avez votre permis
tous les dix ans vous avez besoin et ce
qui est normal parce qu'il ya des gens
qui peuvent passer sous traitement il ya
des gens qui peuvent être dépressif qui
peut avoir des traitements lourds donc
tous les dix ans vous refaites un
contrôle quasiment dans tous les pays
européens puis tous les cinq ans à
partir de 60 ou 65 ans dans certains
pays européens
vous avez besoin d'un contrôle donc un
mini permis de conduire et surtout un
certificat médical
c'était à ksar engage un médecin donc
c'est important puisque le médecin votre
médecin généraliste est censé savoir
tous les traitements que vous pouvez
avoir
donc ça ça me paraît quelque chose
d'assez sérieux et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi en allemagne en france
effectivement il ya un regret imminent
qui est fait comment les éminentes sinon
refaire passer son permis de conduire
oui à 70 ans non je suis pas d'accord
avec ça ah non moi je suis d'accord
un vrai contrôle suivi tous les cinq ans
gilles verdez bien sûr que si le
chauffard de 89 ans dont on parle il
avait abolition du discernement
syndromes démentiels et conduisait sa
croyance incroyable c'est impossible ce
monsieur ne pouvait plus conduire
n'était plus en responsabilité de rien
du tout et le drame est arrivé
donc quand on voit ça il faut légiférer
pour le moment il ya juste un contrôle
qui peut aboutir à ce que le préfet
demande un examen c'est un martyr du
code de la route mais c'est bidon il
faut faire repasser avec un examen
médical aux plus de 70 ans
c'est indispensable aujourd'hui benjamin
alors le grand paradoxe c'est que quand
vous avez un retrait de permis
quand on vous retire le permis et que
vous leur passé on vous demande de faire
des examens de votre agilité de la
vision de louis où nous faire une prise
de sang
ça c'est quand on perd son permis il
faut c'est pas la question c'est parce
qu'il faut le retirer à tous les ans il
faut des 60 ans qu'à passer des tests de
d'acuité parce que c'est pas un problème
ou vont le perdre c'est quoi c'est le cd
code de la route et faire un tour avec
un mec à côté c'est pas ça du tout il
faut que les gens soient testés sur leur
capacité réelle à conduire c'est la
vision c'est les réflexes sinon ça ne
servira à rien et et ce qui me tue c'est
que effectivement d'en cas d'annulation
de permis
tout ça on le fait passer à la des gens
qui ont 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans alors hervé
sauzay vous êtes président de l'institut
français des seniors iii foncé sur
quatre sont favorables à une visite
médicale dès 65 ans concernant le permis
de conduire vous est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils doivent les personnes de plus de
soixante dix ans doivent repasser leur
permis
sa part est une ce qui est arrivé à
maxime d'abord dire ça est horrible et
il n'y a rien qui justifie ça évidemment
et c'est là la raison qu'on a tous en
tête falala mesure plutôt qu'on a tous
en tête la correction ça serait de dire
on va contrôler tous ces gens là parce
que tous ces seniors là sont dangereux
là dessus je veux dire deux choses dans
les pays européens c'est pas tous les
pays européens pardon ces quatre pays
européens qui qui imposaient des
contrôles réguliers
ce qu'on observe c'est comme ça c'est
les chiffres c'est que ça n'a pas fait
baisser la mortalité
ça ne marche pas c'est dire le fait de
faire des contrôles c'est pas la bonne
méthode ça pourrait être la bonne
méthode tout montrait ravi tout le monde
accepte très dur les contrôler ses nerfs
même très d'accord pour les faire les
seniors aujourd'hui ils s'auto limite
même les gens qui voient mal ils
conduisent pas la nuit par exemple est
ce qu'on parkinson vous prennent des
voitures automatiques parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils ont une difficulté
donc en fait le yen c'est une mesure qui
ne qui ne fonctionne pas donc ce qui
plus utiles afin c'est la deuxième
remarque pardon c'est que le sujet à mon
avis c'est pas la barre et la barrière
d'âge parce que plus on avance en âge
plus différent d'une personne à l'autre
en termes de capacité sont dites sont
sont très différentes d'une personne à
l'autre
donc on va dire 60 ans 70 ans déjà en
pleine forme et où est sûr et puis il y
en a qui ne sont pas en forme à 50 ans
est donc en fait on a travaillé beaucoup
sur ce sujet là avec des médecins
spécialistes et des spéciales de
sécurité routière qui explique en fait
le sujet c'est de détecter et c'est ce
qui est arrivé malheureusement alors
pour l'accès dans votre papa c'est la
perte de capacité
c'est ça le sujet est donc ce n'est pas
l'âge donc les les mesures qui dirait à
partir 70 ans tout le monde à l'examen
en plus on sait pas faire il ya eu mille
médecins spécialisés sécurité routière
on appelle médecins généralistes agréé
sécurité routière qui pourrait être
d'ailleurs treki qui sont en france ne
peuvent pas contrôler eu 6 millions de
plus de 75 ans c'est juste pas possible
donc
et en plus politiquement dernier élément
celui le gouvernement qui décide de
faire contrôler tous les seniors c comme
celui qui décidera de leur faire un
confinement spéciales hyper l'élection
oppose la folle d'affaires faut le dire
comme ça pourquoi donc il faut attendre
aucun gouvernement si à droite ou de
gauche n'a voulu prendre cette mesure
cette décision là et c'est pas pour rien
mais c'est passé c'est parce que ça ne
fonctionne pas et aussi parce que c'est
un c'est pas aux entendent à part la
population en revanche il ya des moyens
de prévention qui peuvent être mis en
mis en oeuvre par les deux stages trois
benjamins le lie à des par exemple à sa
autour de saint-etienne dans une petit
village s'appelle petite maison qu'ils
appellent la fouillouse le maire s'est
entendu avec l'auto école locale pour
envoyer les seniors militer médecin mère
qui voyait qu'ils avaient des
difficultés dans l est donc passé un
test et quand quand il y avait le
moniteur d'auto école à côté
le seigneur entendait qu'effectivement
là il avait fait une bêtise
institué en allemagne ou dans vous
parliez les stages sont gratuits et sont
volontaires
je crois beaucoup plus à ce qui est
volontaire ce qui est de ce qui est du
domaine de la prévention et de
l'incitation que ce qui est du domaine
de la sanction et puis les médecins gré
sécurité routière dont je parlais
rapidement du salaire sont des médecins
qui sont spécialistes pour détecter
quand une personne n'est plus capable à
un certain nombre de difficultés et
n'est plus capable de conduire
et vous pouvez parfaitement faut le dire
la liste et sur tous les sites internet
des préfectures il y en a à peu près 10
par département quand vous avez
quelqu'un de votre famille qui à cette
difficulté de n'envoyer qu'elles
commencent à sauter commence à poser les
problèmes sur la route et vous pouvez
l'envoyer là bas mais je veux dire une
chose c'est que là on est dans une
région parisienne en campagne les gens
ont besoin de conduire les gens bossent
cher dès leur liberté et c'est les
enfants qui refusent que les parents
refusent qu'on retire le parent le
permis aux personnes âgées
bernard montiel on sait très bien que
les personnes âgées en général sont
suivis par des médecins dont je crois
qu'il faudrait lever dans ces cas là le
peut-être le secret médical
s'il ya des cas très graves et dans ces
cas là parce que pour moi ce serait non
assistance à personne en danger
voyez donc vous avez raison mais c'est
juridiquement impossible on a creusé le
sujet a été créée creuser récemment par
les différents ministères concernés en
france c'est impossible secret médical
il est absolu ça s'appelle comme ça il y
avait eu connaissance d'un cas d'une
personne qui était médecin du travail et
qui voyait une conductrice de car
scolaire qui qui était alcoolique et il
n'avait pas le droit de le dénoncer
donc c'est donc c'est un sujet qui est
complexe dans lequel je crois que il
faut se méfier un de stigmatiser deux
d'aller trop vite
voilà et 3 de généraliser je crois que
et que c'est toujours dans une
discussion en one to one avec la
personne âgée avec l'aide de la famille
du médecin traitant qu'il ya un gros
rôle qui peut vraiment bien sûr qui peut
convaincre la personne agissant sur
machin quand même là quand vous avez
vous était arrivé on marchait pas bien à
quoi j'ai préféré maxime quand vous
entendez tout ça vous avez perdu votre
papa c'est un chauffard de 89 ans j'ai
envie de dire quoi vous envie de dire on
sait en fait ça n'a pas fait avancer les
choses
c'est ça parce qu'en fait vous aimeriez
que ça n'arrive plus et il avait perdu
votre papa et c'est un drame vraiment
incroyable et moi même nous c'est vrai
que ça nous a tous peinés on pense ma
pensé à vous maintenant à chaque fois
qu'on va voir une personne âgée au
volant c'est sûr qu'on a pensé à vous et
à votre papa votre famille et vous
aimeriez que ça ne se reproduise plus
mais voyez que ça avance pas en fait ce
soir et surtout que la personne de 80
ans justement qui a qui a tué mon père
on peut le dire
suite aux procédures juridiques et tout
ça a enfin eu un test médical et a été
jugée de sénile
donc au final il n'a rien eu suite à
l'accident
c'est ça le problème c'est la capacité
cognitive je me permets de faire un
petit aparté pour dire que quelques
pistes cognitive de contrôle il ya trois
sujets des trois dangers sur la sur la
conduite atteindre la part des seniors
il ya la vision vous avez fait allusion
on quand on voit mal il ya les
médicaments et dans les médicaments les
premiers première cause d'accidents dus
aux médicaments c'est les psychotropes
il n'y a pas que les seniors qui bouffe
de l'anxiolytique et de l'antidépresseur
et enfin il ya les problèmes cognitifs
et dans les problèmes cognitifs
on perd ses capacités la capacité à
coordonner c'est pour ça que la majorité
des accidents de seniors se passe à des
intersections
parce que c'est compliqué de gérer la
venue sur site et ça mais quand vous
êtes bourrés et que vous avez dit
cannabis il concerne toutes les
populations ça concerne pas les seniors
le seigneur pour ce n'est pas la même
chose
c'est la même chose et donc vous savez
que alcool + cannabis juste passer un
message d'une seconde alcool + cannabis
1 x 29 le risque d'accident des messages
de prévention à la télévision comment
pas rouler avec de l'alcool ne pas
rouler avec de la drogue
voilà il ya de la prévention de la
prévention sur les personnes âgées il ya
de l'information n'est pas allé au bout
d'informations qu'on pourrait fermer à
vis des personnes âgées qui sont en plus
tout à fait prête à l'entendre plus
sauvegardé faut-il faire repasser le
permis
les seniors de plus de 70 ans oui à 64%
nous à 36%
maxime je vous remercie d'avoir été là
comme ceux ci et on va penser très fort
à vous merci à garder le moral et
vraiment on espère que les choses ont
bougé merci avait sonné président de
l'institut français des seniors merci
beaucoup